see this has been down low enough to do
that ones right out of bounds like
there's like six turnovers
[Music]
throwing it down six on the 24 had it
inbounds to Marvin Bagley and he's on
the board
be careful he'll put you in the bucket
factly again on the weak side that's now
15 points and eight rebounds for the
rookie out of Duke it's good patience
and there is Begley Jr right there at
the rim hopping on Mason factly with a
steal see you later
off the bench with 10 points
[Music]
can anybody stop the rookie from Duke
Barban Bagley
so much talent in a good kid and he
works extremely hard that's the part I
love about and look at that passed by
faculty to the cutting Frank Mason
shouldn't have no question you were
right on it tough shot
oh and there's Bagley walking in and
dunking at home Bagley from Jackson
sitting that rookie from Duke to the
line yes they did
Marvin directing traffic nice little
screen delivery great hands on the
interior grant and the ability to kiss
it off the glass with us there's Lyles
rookie stolen by cauley-stein here comes
Sacramento now 13 numbers three on one
oh boy nothing but nylon and mint out in
transition two young fellows grant takes
the foul and delivers at the basket
sweet defense right there by bloodied oh
hello the block shot the second of the
game from back and they trail it by 11
Oh a block shot by factly is second team
rebounds for Hassan Whiteside and five
rejections back Lee is in oh what a pass
to buddy Hill Wow that's behind their
line finds close to Koufos no good back
Lee one trouble
oh if you don't like that you don't like
Kings basketball Marvin Bagley how about
that eglee lord push shot by Costa
Marvin grabs the rebound and then he
says I thank you very much
then gloriously does it mr. Bagley with
two points how about the recovery by
Bagley to block that shot get Deadshot
out of here since mr. Bhagu he left the
pole the LOB in the flush what a setup
and again the Kings repeating the Spurs
down the floor Bagley if they can get
him the ball there is Bagley no back leg
look at that work and a chance for three
play gets a capella screen attacks
Marvin Bagley fought fight back we will
go the other way
covers for the Kings it's a four on -
snorting Carmelo Anthony started off one
in five bitten on all cylinders right
now and there's badly with a dump in a
foul see right here both Donnie misses
it Marvin's in to grab it and say I
could do it backwards too baby
Sacramento gets the shot by Jackson
grant attacking blocked by Morgan Bagley
and he saves the ball Wow is right here
comes Polk down of it nice pass 89 85
mad at Jackson Jackson Bagley the number
two pick in the NBA draft for your
Sacramento Kings Marvin Bagley has the
bag he jumps up that says give me that
shot takes it and gets out on his horse
drop it into the post
nice little left
nice pass Pat's up first a home do this
precious like that that is sure lettuce
is about a marvelous law be healed you
see I'm gonna put it on the deck Begley
catches that and puts it there oh I
thought you dumped it with one hand
grant to have to be kidding me
this young man we talked about a star in
the making just breaks down your old
defense is to own bad week so again the
game is basically where it was yeah it's
a big advantage for Sacramento and that
is a beautiful physical bogey comes into
the game and just it's like just
clockwork slapped away by Mason turnover
numbers
nice finish Marvin factory how about
back taketh bogey out in open court
throws it up says young fella you do the
rest just badly again charge wow that
was easy wasn't it man made the one way
bringing back the other nice and soft
with the left hand he first missing this
quarter for Minnesota's 305 now the LOB
and Oh back to the basket
no problem that got 98-94 grabbed it
backwards into it for you Matt Bagley
off the deflection Bagley stays with it
and scores how about that second jump by
Marvin Bagley or for Lillard and he
throws it away
another Portland turnover fox kind of
reminds you of the Lakers it was Kobe
after shackle if you keep them around
and then you allow Kobe to close the
game similar to a bow and one is right
here grant this is the isolation II knew
exactly what he was gonna do right
Johnson Johnson knocked away by badly
numbers for the Kings three on two JJ
[Applause]
the way you talk about setting up the
pic fella again gotta put it up there
and let it fly little bit rusty elites a
three-point shooter Shumpert takes
threes they're not playing tonight nice
pass how about Bagley to Willie
cauley-stein that was nicely done chef a
guitar that's a foul on Sacramento you
know we looked at Begley right there in
the middle of this ascending mount
working out his tenth rebound and dump
career-high 22 his soft hands able to
keep control the ball look at that quick
step in there you are I mean come on
he is so good but we hear stoning he
doesn't have the gorgeous a stroke that
that a klay Thompson Arjun BC good luck
the brake caliber 'no swear not this
really athletic but knows how to get all
the spots on the floor he needs to badly
to the baseline all star kind of stuff
which is quit spin it's by herder and
then how about a little major slamming
john the other side that's the hard part
allies getting away from the dead money
on the wave boards good job defensively
I mean bag leads as showing out there
made that chomp little tougher
[Applause]
[Music]
exactly with the rebound
don't get a chance at a three-point play
Atalaya powder stumbling we break losing
it
yogi Ferrell open court yogi pushing a
handbook - Marvin Bagley from yogi
Ferrell put it on the platter boy yogi
pushing the ball sees heads-up sees the
Marvin just sprinting past a couple
defenders that's just a great house for
playing how much - Marvin Paul's heart
where you really come to it what a pass
Oh Marvin Bagley - yogi Ferrell a thing
of beauty you drop it there you go
things almost turn it over Bagley be
careful here Marvin spinning and scoring
and the Kings just like that buy the
game $13 tucked in as a pocket square
yeah
or move by very creative but I was gonna
do
Wow Marvin Bagley with the windmill
slash
the process it's got to be the Darren
Fox show
it was a very difficult fast between the
last last chance 360 flat
take another look here this is Bagley
getting that 360 slam after everyone
couldn't get to fall turnover it would
Allah
nut Brooks pokes it away in a good job
alec burks
says thank you very much
[Applause]
trust yourself get yourself some good
shots and create for your teammates is
likely drop step off beautiful move by
Marvin Bagley if you're gonna have him
shooting it as opposed to curry or
Durant he's got to be okay with that
Oh Marvin Bagley you'll take them anyway
can get them right now
104 102 that's 24 from Orban Bagley it
is and you watch right here to pull up I
know Marvin did not call glass but
nonetheless it counts
Bagley thanks pastor Harry Giles that's
a thing of beauty
timeout Thunder oh boy in fact he wants
to work on the bow is gonna have to
hurry
gotta hurry Marvin slightly at the
pleasure town it
Marvin Bagley with thirteen
boy he's no good
59-51
so free-throws upcoming farms kiss up
slow I don't you damn bag Lincoln Fox
how beautiful was that cup Christa don't
how was the beautiful as it gets right
there no good cars big rebound Bagley
Martin back do it
104 with this shooting but I'll tell you
right now these guys have plant some
good basketball and coach Anker is
saying look it this is what I'm gonna
roll with right now he also has 12
points recognition by Coors brewery
batter just like you called it there
should be two points bottom others
quick double-team and in back bagley
takes some contact
Marvin family and a chance for a
three-point play all up and gets the
hoop
that's a remarkable play
things look to run for Bulls about
Bagley fatales get used to that Kings
fans do they say that for many many
years to come active hands there by
Corey Brewer Marvin bacala about this
little spin move little kiss off the
window on now especially deep shooters
and things happen to connect splendid
that part of it
Bagley says thank you very much the
Aaron Fox well Fox is simply on his own
broke down the defense received the
errand in the open court really just the
spits of the offense signs Marvin Bagley
need to call those out a little better
box elevates missed it stays healthier
gonna be a factor
Giles but move here by wow you got
Marvin back oh you know you can score
easy for anything he can't do I haven't
seen it hope so
you know I want to get back here's
Marvin Bagley again now watch this
incredible reverse yeah just a little
flip underneath the basket yes he uses
his right hand here with the dribble to
get by the defender nice gotta love the
game hit a lot you back back Lee from
Barnes
[Applause]
great reaping box gets by one box from
the foul line says hello Marvin I see
you and Fox with another assist
[Music]
nice pass faculty to brewery this
patient TRICARE by Corey Brewer new
Devin Harris is coming to uses the shot
fake did begin this is when you need to
pick up some ground you have training on
the backhoe here comes the rookie
everybody could do that you're exactly
right Graham and that I think it's a
credit to Chris Paul understanding as I
hate beautifully done by Marvin Bagley
well right what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content